all right listen up Melissa's in
Virginia and I'm Melissa how are you
Melissa
call Dave oh my gosh how blessing to
hear your voice um yes I wanted to so my
estranged husband came back in this to
the house so after two and a half years
and wanting I'm having a hard time for
one on a trust level and then also doing
the finances with him right now he's
skeptical because you know he's still
trying to find a full time he's just
doing jobs here and there so how do I
just go about I'm just a little
reluctant on combining out finances you
know after our separation it was a
surprise that he came back he wanted to
surprise me on my birthday
and so I'm just having a hard time with
our family if your estranged you kind of
have to get permission to come back
correct but you know he even though I
was kind of refusing him before he
wanted to come back and you know just
you know say you know in addition to me
so when your party I want to also come
back and you know so I wasn't really
trying to downplay him ribbon around his
chest and said I'm here happy birthday
got me
you know abruptly here oh man I pulled
your romantic string okay so have you
guys done any marriage counseling while
you were estranged
oh no no on the voice of divorce you
always you know you are starting
marriage counseling today yes we've been
back we have been counseling with the
pastor that that Mary that's initially
what is the posture say about you not
wanting to trust him well he was just
saying that he
to do a little bit more to you know earn
trust who you know that yeah the person
he's having a hard time with that and
haven't been but then he's also been
trying to look for a job and he don't
want to hear anything that you know I'm
doing his I've been knowing you for
about a couple of months now and I'm
just starting also on baby stuff once so
I'm like here's the thing until he is
worthy of trust it is illogical for you
to trust him and he's worthy when he has
a is actually doing things not talking
about them why he's gotten jobs here and
there but not really really a lot and
doesn't do a lot and that's why you
don't trust him
his actions don't meet his audio doesn't
match his video his actions his actions
don't match his mouth and until it does
it's illogical for you to trust him I'm
not saying he can't get there but hey
I'm home now I don't like the way you're
doing this and I'm not gonna work much
that's what I heard
yeah he was working deadpan there until
he found what he really wants to do
full-time but you know it's just he's
just being discouraged and depressing
and I'm like oh my god I don't need all
this energy back in the house whole way
I think you guys are in a reconciliation
period hopefully you're in a healing
period for your marriage and hopefully
he's in a healing period with his
attitude and his work ethic and then
that makes him you know if he's there a
year and he works a lot and you guys
have a lot of discussions and he makes
good money and he's helping to take care
of his family like he's supposed to and
then you can talk and be a year then you
could talk about combining your finances
but I wouldn't combine them today I
wouldn't because I think you're you
essentially are separated while still in
the same roof right now because your
relationship is not healed as a matter
of fact that we don't know that it's
going to I hope it does that's my prayer
for you and I hope
your pastor can lead you guys through
some good discussions and him to some
personal responsibility because in order
for someone to be trusted they have to
be trust worthy worthy of the trust and
that is based on actions not talk and
that's true of employees lawyers should
be true of politicians it's not and it
should be true of spouses and children
you want me to trust you and behave in
such a way that makes me naturally do
that then you combine your finances
where's your marriage heels
I sure hope it does kiddo